how did you get from the beginning to
where you are now
Lloyd well tell you we're here we're
celebrating entrepreneurs of which Mike
is terrific and a fabulously successful
entrepreneur I joined I joined an
ongoing concern but I did you know
you're right I grew up in Brooklyn East
New York linden project's Thomas
Jefferson high school I went to great
schools I came out I practiced law for a
while and then tried to get a job on
Wall Street because I thought it was the
most interesting exciting place to go in
New York City a financial town I found I
couldn't get a job anywhere for reasons
that are probably very appropriate at
the time I finally got a job at a
commodity trading firm which is kind of
on the lower prestige end of that of
that gradient and that firm was acquired
by Goldman Sachs that's how I got my job
at Goldman Sachs but you had to have
been extraordinarily scrappy to get
yourself from being part of jaren to the
top of Goldman well like a lot of people
in New York City coming through the
public school system you had to be you
were you were one of those salmon that
made it upstream that's for sure might
you turn down Goldman Sachs
back in the day got turned and turned
down Goldman Sachs and then the only
reason I became an entrepreneur is I got
fired by Salomon Brothers it should
happen to you trust me it works out I
hope it doesn't happen well I have no
intention of doing it don't worry about
it thirty years ago what was your
motivation what did you want to become
I don't remember sitting there fifty
there were forty eight years ago when I
got out of graduate school saying I know
for sure what I want to do I was
supposed to go to Vietnam at the last
minute they wouldn't take me because of
flat feet a friend of mine said go to
Wall Street talk to a firm goldman sachs
and Salomon Brothers and Hutzler
the guy's name was Steve Fenster he was
a McNamara Wizkid's he knew something
about Wall Street I said who are those
firms what do they do he's just do it
and both were lucky and I was lucky
enough that both offered me a job I
thought I fit in Salomon a little bit
better went there and had 15 great years
it was fun it was exciting I Love New
York and every day was good
after the day I got fired and even that
was interesting and then I started a
business the next day but I think once
you got through that Lloyd's career and
mine have been very similar neither of
us are slow diplomatic patrician kind of
people we say what's on our mind every
once in a while you wish I hadn't every
once in a while somebody hates you for
it but at least people know when you
talk to Lloyd Blankfein that's what he
really means God you see right through
me I thought I was my version of that I
know Lloyd for you what did you feel
thirty years ago what did you want to
become did you walk in and say I'm gonna
be CEO of this place was that your goal
let me tell you to be perfectly honest
and this may disappoint you I walked in
the first day and said I hope I make it
to the second day
can I feel though YouTube well I was
just trying to get by I don't believe it
I'll tell you you know there's a lot of
Mythology in the world and a lot of
people think this but I am in awe and
again I don't know have a mayor thing
because again he was an entrepreneur and
he went all-in on an idea built a big
company but let's face it I joined a
class of other people who was striving I
knew that the 30 people that started
with me after a year that only be 20
after another year after that they'd
only be 10 and I'm thinking to myself
gee I hope I can fool them for another
week another month another year